la ley de nueva york que tumba hoy la
corte suprema pues restringía el porte
de armas en espacios públicos y limitado
el porte de armas a los hogares sin
embargo la corte suprema de mayoría
conservadora seis de seis de los nueve
magistrados votaron para restringir esta
ley diciendo que va en contra de la
segunda enmienda de eeuu concretamente
claro insisto mans que de hecho es uno
de los magistrados que más apoya el
porte de armas en eeuu escribió esta
opinión este fallo dijo que iba no
solamente en contra de la segunda
enmienda sino también de la enmienda
decimocuarta dijo textualmente que estas
enmiendas permiten a los individuos el
porte de armas para defensa personal y
que leyes estatales no pueden entrar en
contradicción con estas dos enmiendas
recordemos que este es un caso que ya se
había debatido y se había opinado al
respecto en ocasiones anteriores y surge
de dos ciudadanos del estado de nueva
york que pues demandan al estado por no
sé por no poder portar sus armas al
trabajo y no poder portar estas armas
más allá de espacios de casa donde si se
les había permitido pero se les había
prohibido precisamente cortarlas en
espacios públicos y qué implicaciones
trae esta decisión cuando hay un debate
nacional y todo el impulso de los
demócratas para restringir el porte de
ciertas armas por los recientes tiroteos
lo que dice el otro juez de la corte de
suprema stephen breyer que de hecho
sales son sus últimas semanas en la
corte suprema porque va a ser
reemplazado porque también brawn jackson
lo que dice este señor es que va a
limitar mucho más a los estados para
poder limitar el porte de armas esto en
medio de más de 300 tiroteos que se han
presentado en eeuu desde el principio de
año y que limitará además pues
precisamente eso que los estados puedan
poner restricciones a quien puede
comprar las armas hay que mencionar que
esta restricción que tenía en que el
estado de nueva york la tenía también el
estado de nueva jersey california hawai
maryland entre otros y estos estados
entonces son los que se van a ver
sobretodo afectados porque pues esta
segunda en bien de la enmienda décimo
cuarta como lo argumenta la mayoría
conservadora en la corte suprema de
justicia pues giran sobre estas leyes
estatales y pues él va a limitar
entonces a estos estados para que puedan
tomar pues riendas de los problemas
estatales además de que mencionar que
ésta próximo a pasarse en el senado una
ley bipartidista precisamente para
limitar el porte as más a nivel federal
así que es contradictorio que por un
lado el congreso apruebe leyes para
restringir el porte de armas pero por
otro lado la corte suprema pues dé vía
libre a el importe de armas de
individuos en su legítima defensa